hey guys this is andrew for
trailingcensus.com
and in today's video i want to talk
about
gold
[Music]
alright so once again on this kind of
charts when i want to
have a long-term view to understand
where we could be possibly heading
and for what reasons i like to use a
logarithmic
scale so here i'm using a logarithmic
scale
and i'm gonna watch for example what
happened in the past 10 years
so once again as i said before i don't
really like
horizontal trend line even if they're
helpful
but but so let's make one here but you
see
it has not been actually playing out
here
or little it got above it and i'm going
to show you why
it came here actually using my tools
using what i think is working because
i'm
using it for a long time and i'm going
to show you how in this video very
quickly
i don't want to spoil you guys but it's
a it's going to be about fibonacci
again you're going to see um
so basically what happened let's look at
it even in the
longer term all right so i take a weekly
chart
and i go back here okay
i have here guys a 40 years of data on
gold
40 years of data you can find some very
interesting behaviors
so first thing i like trend lines
so i'm gonna make a trend line here
you see this is giving you so much more
information once this is broken
things just change very
differently and once again you can see
we break it
and guys here we had a retest i always
say
don't buy the breakout wait for the
retest the retest
almost always happens you wait for it
you need to not too formal if you form
more guys
you're buying here and then here you
might be cutting your positions
because you're you're stressing because
you're losing money so you're not buying
the breakout you wait so here you could
have bought it anyway
this was in 203 let's go back to what is
happening right now so we had this first
move
all right bearish one for 20 years
and then we had this strong move up
where we were training above the 200
period moving averages
basically the 20 and the 50 were playing
um
were acting as support the whole way up
so those were interesting to to to look
at
then 2 or 12 same very strange
for a couple of years
until two or twenty guys where
things have changed completely
so here i started to be bullish on gold
for the same reasons i'm giving you
since the beginning
i'm doing these videos the market
is unfolding in ways so you need to spot
the waves
and once a wave is done you know that
we're
going for a new one and then you need to
use fibonacci
to know how far we can go so once again
if you like what i'm talking about hit
the like button subscribe to the channel
because i'm gonna
give you guys some very amazing content
in the coming
days i'm gonna do some videos on
fibonacci
on idiot wave if you uh subscribe to my
newsletter you're gonna receive a free
video
but i'm gonna post some videos for free
as well on my youtube channel
please subscribe so let's go back to
this chart here
we were bullish at 1300 um
and the target was actually here i'm
gonna show you why guys
as i always do fib extension if you use
fib extension of this move
and you apply it here because once
i don't want to do back training too
much but you're going to see in my
videos
that the levels i'm going to give you
right now
are going to actually act as
support or resistance levels in the
coming weeks
month you're going to see that and so
here
i could have found this level by using
the golden ratio look it it's exactly
2080 was the golden ratio
what is the maximum here
it was 2 or 30. i would have missed it
but i would have been very close so if i
would have put the target just below
this golden ratio i would have bought
here
and sold here it would have been a very
nice trade
this is behind us what is coming what is
coming guys
where are we once again we're not going
to use the 200 period uh
moving average as a support level
because as we saw
it didn't act like this for the uh
10 years bull market we had here we're
gonna use the 50 under 20 all right
those are the ones we are going to use
so
now we just broke the 20 because you
were very extended
so i'm bullish on this because i think
that the economic outlook
is actually not so nice
uh despite all the efforts that are made
by central banks to sustain the economy
by
injecting money and reducing the taxes
stuff like this
i'm still convinced that some bigger
damage has been done to the economy
and that we're gonna fill it in the
coming month
years uh decade yes decade guys
so i think that gold is gonna push
higher because it's a safe haven
so i wanna buy this i wanna buy this and
i would buy it
like around the 50 period moving average
and if it goes lower i'm gonna put more
um i wouldn't put a big position and i
wouldn't use a stop loss
because it's i want to have this in my
portfolio that's it
actually i have some already uh some
physical gold
but i want to have some um paper gold as
well
so here uh my level to buy is 7
1750 or 60
or even 7 even 1800 all right
i could buy very soon and if it goes
lower i buy more
what are my targets
my targets as as usual i use the golden
ratio guys so the one-to-one
relationship
brings us to 2700 so this would be my
first target i could upload some of my
long position here if we reach this
level uh in
by the end of 2022 um but my real target
guys my real target for the coming
decade is
three thousand seven hundred all right
i think the gold is going there and
roughly it's going to use
the same growth it has it had here
so that's why projections are very
useful because
if i protect this move here we're going
to go to 2700
um roughly in two or twenty three
something like this two twenty two two
and two or three twenty three
so yeah and where could we put some stop
loss
or could we think that things are
turning is
if we break this 200 period moving
average which is now at 1500 all right
so
let's say it comes like somewhere here
okay so and the market is going like
this
all right and here we break the fib
level 38.2 and we break the
200 period moving average around 1650
maybe
it would be in october 21 so july
whatever you know within six months
something like this then i would
reconsider everything i
could turn bearish but i need to have
some
more um information about the economic
outlook
that it's going better so i'm going to
look at the inflation and i'm going to
look at the growth all right because
what is
the only thing that can go against the
fed
plan is if the inflation is going too
high all right
because they're printing too much money
so once so one day the inflation is
gonna
uh come back to the economy brutally
right now we have the inflation in the
assets
in for example the the market in
everything that people
invest money but we don't have inflation
in the real economy
and when this inflation is going to come
so for example the price of bread you
know things like this
then the fed would have no other choice
than raising rates
raising rates and look how indebted
they are all the countries in the world
if the rates are going higher i can tell
you guys that we
are in big troubles so i'm gonna very
i'm gonna be
very um so i'm gonna look very carefully
what are the inflation prices and if
suddenly the impression the inflation is
much higher than expected
it's the time to
catch a long positions on the equity and
to think about buying more gold
more crypto i don't know that's it for
me i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and as i always say tight stop loss and
stay close to shore
see you guys